[Music]
so the guy who attacked dave chappelle
is back on the news oh i heard about it
you heard about that
what happened yeah he's a fight he's
fine he got like a
conference stabbing his roommate or
something yeah
but that's where he's getting charged
what happened before because they were
basically looking for him from that
crime yeah
way back yeah so his previous roommate
stabbed him so he was wanted for
attempted murder
and he kind of just outed uh where he
was once that dave chappelle thing kind
of gained traction and went everywhere
then they were like oh there he is did
he use that gun
it's the same rep the same knife still
has blood on it i don't it doesn't say
that he used that but uh he probably has
a nice collection of weird knives i'm
sure it was something else well damn
that makes that a little scarier than
right if he was willing to stab his
roommate he might have actually stabbed
dave chappelle and it was a uh it was
one of those transitional housing so it
wasn't like
it's not like he had a like a place he's
like this guy's
in a transitional housing means he
probably did something else too before
yeah that's what uh dave chappelle is
saying like he's like i got tackled by
someone leaves in his hair
[Laughter]
he obviously isn't doing that well where
do you get tickets to go see dave
chappelle yeah there's a line out the
door i don't know man
fudge and those tickets are not they're
not cheap maybe he was sitting outside
and then you know like that's something
for money and someone just dropped a
stub
somebody in line
that's what happened do this exactly and
how did he get through security with a
knife what the hell yeah that's what's
crazy that gun shape yeah a gunship is a
gun shaped knife what the d8 dropped
charges too right well they reduced the
charges so i've reduced it not to a
felony to like a misdemeanor because he
didn't use the you know why he's one of
those crisis actors
they've rebooked so next week there's
going to be like a plane crash and he's
going to be one of the people running
out of fire like oh with the knight
he's always got his
he's the knife guy i recognized him from
dave chappelle show hire that guy it has
to be hit and miss with security because
like i went to the fair just last week
the l.a county fair yeah security guards
are like 13. what's going on right now
yeah it it yeah i guess they did it may
instead of september because they're
scared there's going to be another
shutdown and they want to make money so
they didn't want a pomona yeah um but
yeah the security i brought my backpack
because i brought my camera and he's
like oh i got to check your backpack i'm
like all right open it up and he just
goes like this he's like is this it i
was like he's like oh you're good i'm
like damn i could have had so much other
[ __ ] under the camera
oh i thought he pulled out a knife he's
like this it's only a three inch blade
you're good hey when we went and then a
couple couple weeks or yeah a couple
weeks ago we went to legoland no
security check at all at legoland we
just walked in who's gonna shoot up
legoland though yeah you know what's
known as girl disneyland they're
thorough when you walk through they like
look at everything they pick it up and
we bring a stroller and even on the
stroller they're like looking at all
kinds of [ __ ] i'm like wow two stages of
security at disneyland there's downtown
disney and then once you get past
downtown disney and then before you get
into disneyland actually yeah it's
freaking i also heard the buzz lightyear
ride does an x-ray as you leave
no that's a beam
for that game where you're like shooting
the targets i'm so imagine above and
beyond but security
got him that'd be a funny way to hide it
though in a ride it's like uh the tsa
thing they should let it ride they
should hide their security better that
kind of is gone now that i wish like i
was able to see
the gilroy garlic festival it's gone oh
because it got it got shot up you got a
shot and then kovit took them out
because
because of like they don't have any more
money to like throw the event so there's
garlic rotting there because like what
else is that space for i don't know that
whole town's just garlic life does it
still smell like it yeah you drive past
it yeah it's because a lot of garlic
farms they should spin it call it the
garlic ghost town
it's haunted now
you can smell the ghost of garlic and
you see the breath of the ghost you're
good at marketing man this one's really
good garlic ghost towel the town man
right coming in save the day and if you
need a toe we have garlic toe in town
our drivers have the best breath every
toe comes with garlic bread
garlic bread because you've been
probably waiting for a while
oh dude i would love to get toad then
yeah
that sounds like a dress you need to
make a tow truck made out of like garlic
like you know how oscar meyer has that
hot dog mobile instead of armor all it's
just garlic oil and god spread it
everywhere you never thought about
adding some like wacky addition to like
like a perk to being like a gimmick
company to get yeah we even thought we
thought about giving the unboxing uh
boxing glove key chains
and then so like hey dude thank you so
much if ever in trouble just look at
your keychain and then freaking and then
we'll come in
cause are you guys all fighters and then
you have a tow truck company and they
[ __ ] you up dude
it's called knockout toy yeah knockout
the the logo is already like a boxer
with boxing gloves so we just have the
that and then the number and that'll be
plenty of the jojo drivers wearing
boxing gloves all the time
and he can't do his job
he's talking to me a couple seconds what
are you saying oh let me take my
mouthpiece off
he's all sorry he's gonna take a while
but the uh the customer can't look for
the job so we can have them just punch
the tablet instead of signifies like
here you've officially been ko'd thank
you sir
that'd be dope it'll be funny if they
call you and you guys pull up and start
sparring with him
if you have any complaints let me take
you to the complete department if you
can beat me your toe is free exactly
it's like an 80 year old lady she's like
all right dear
i was like oh snap she has hands
oh my god yeah i was a four-time boxing
golden glove champion back in 1940
and she's still alive bro dude old
people still forget do you see that
video with the old dude like in lighting
up that young dude yeah
the sweater yeah oh yeah wait is this
like in public or at a match
yeah some young dude was going a
thousand percent though he was [ __ ]
up that dude he looked like he was
[ __ ] up a hip like a yoga instructor
yeah but that yoga instructor was like
freaking like
yeah yeah what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do and the old guy's like
yeah the other guy's like i'm like
that's ron when he's old dude
oh yeah but with a long freaking
he caught him with overhand though
is justice yes
that'll be a pretty good branding though
knockout
towing you come here and get knocked the
[ __ ] out start with the keychain and
then do the sparring just [ __ ] that
see how that does first you know test
the waters you should be like street
fighter where you get their card you
start [ __ ] it up
you start beating this shot
i did a video of that because we have
wrecked cars there a lot i played the
freaking street fighter songs like
i was like oh you can't talk too you
were [ __ ] up the car
it was the lexus es uh yeah well ls 402
oh sure the gray one on the dock
at least uh being knockout towing makes
it less likely that someone getting
toad's going to want to fight you to
keep their car when you're towing them
for that reason they get pretty freaking
mean man people are pretty bold these
days what's the meanest person you guys
don't do repo huh no yeah we don't we do
nice but you do but you do towing if
someone's illegally parked somewhere and
someone calls if the property calls us
so like uh like the other week we had a
impound a harley because someone didn't
pay for their storage space so no one
was there like okay we need this out of
here you can tow it and then do whatever
with it so we towed a brand new harley
just put on a flatbed yeah yeah and then
um actually i towed it myself because
everybody was booked and we had an extra
truck so i was like i got in i did it
and then uh which is a hassle by the way
yeah so what do you do ram push it up
yourself yeah it was a flat tire which
makes it worse so i'm like i'm putting a
neutral and it took me like six tries so
i'd run as fast as i could and roll it
up and they slam on the brake and they
get zip ties to zip tie the brake shut
and then with motorcycles though they
don't stay in park so if there's an
incline they go
and it stops
so i have to i have to um get the bed
flat before it falls off the bed wow um
and then they didn't get it they didn't
park it like this where the handlebars
were locked in locked sideways no yeah
yeah luckily the handlebars weren't uh
weren't locked because then you'd have
to put on i don't even know motorcycles
yeah i'd have to slide that lock
that's dumb
[ __ ] flat tire idiot
[ __ ] harley owners
usually they disappear it's usually like
a drug issue or they died or something
like that oh so it's been unpaid for
months so we go out who's yours now yeah
what's up
oh i'm looking for one what would you
say if ron pulls up in a row i want a
48. you have a ton of hell's angels
rolled up your favorite bike
and they're like you got my boys back
yeah i was like all right sir no problem
that'll be a 15 thousand dollars
[ __ ] but i'm gonna give you fifteen
percent off because i i i appreciate
your causing what you do he's like 13k
he's like or we can fight and if you win
i'll give it to you
how many how much would it cost for that
guy to get his bike out
um
it's a 85 dollar hookup
and then 10 bucks some or 15 10 to 15
bucks a mile depending if we work with
and every night right don't you get
charged every five dollars a day
dude that's my old
that might be like 30k like 15k plus
though if they don't pick up their bike
at the storage unit they've already been
gone 30 days or 90 days
there's a good chance that but
they get a notification the registered
owner gets a letter saying that hey it's
in the possession of this tow yard you
know and then when we put a lien in it
they get another notification it's like
hey this company put in for a lien you
have 90 days to
repossess your vehicle but what if he's
stuck in a jungle in southeast asia and
because of kove he can't come here yeah
you ever thought about that ron he's
effed
so if he gets if he brings the doctor's
note
i'll go ahead and submit this thank you
thank you if he gets 20 off
if he arrives in the 89th day to pick it
up
what's his range of cost to get his bike
out more than his worth yeah yeah
because 89 times what 85 you said yeah
at the minimum yeah
it's like 200 dude yeah that's why you
ever get yeah i mean everybody's got
their car towed because they parked some
of their oh you go you go that same day
to go pick up your car and it's like 400
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think in my car i
see my car told all the time because i
was going to la trade tech you know that
mcdonald's right there i didn't want to
pay for the permit so i would always
park there and then they would tow it
and then uh i'm like oh [ __ ] it's not
[ __ ] here and then so i would go and
uh ask mcdonald's like who tows it and
they'd give me the number to go there
and when i go there these shady
[ __ ] would close at like three
so that they can charge you the
overnight fee so by that time i pick it
up yeah it's like three four hundred
bucks i'm like what the and they're
still there you're like hey can i get my
car sorry we're closed yeah i'm like but
you're here though yeah yeah but our
system's close what would you do if you
were sent into a car you get there and
you find out it's a guy that you know
and he's like hey wrong
fifteen percent off
i'm gonna give you the homie hook up
[Music]
[Music]
you